a lo que te quiero introducir en este
vídeo es a una manera de clasificar
números como pares o impares entonces un
número par que quiere decir que un
número sea par o que quiere decir que un
número sea impar un número par es un
número que sí por ejemplo supongamos que
tú tienes una cantidad de donas y quiere
repartir las entre dos personas de tal
forma que ambas obtengan la misma
cantidad sin que sobren donas entonces
un número par es aquel que es múltiplo
de 2
si tú tienes por ejemplo un número
parece aquel que es múltiplo de 2 si tú
tienes dos zonas y dos personas podría
darle una dona a cada quien si tú tienes
cuatro donas
podrías repartirlas entre dos personas
de manera que ambos a ambos le tocan dos
zonas y podemos seguir todos estos son
ejemplos de números pares son múltiplos
de dos y los números pares siguen
indefinidamente ahora una manera fácil
de ver si un número es par es que ese
número en el lugar de las unidades
tendrá un número par entonces por
ejemplo el número 32 tiene un número par
en el lugar de las unidades el 2 es un
número par entonces 32 es un número par
por ejemplo el número
5 millones 977 mil 300
54 en el lugar de las unidades tienen
número par el 4 es paz entonces este
número gigante es un número par ahora un
número interesante que muchas personas
se preguntan si es para o no es el cero
me refiero al cero el cero es un número
par porque es múltiplo de dos ya que 0
por 2 es igual a 0
entonces el 0 es un múltiplo de 2 el 0
es un número par y esto tiene sentido
porque supongamos en este ejemplo
tomemos al número 150 el número 150
tiene en el lugar de las unidades un 0 y
el 0 es un número par por lo tanto 150
es un número par y que podemos concluir
de todo esto bueno pues que si en el
lugar de las unidades tenemos un número
par entonces todo el número será par
ahora vamos con los números impares
cuando un número es impar puedes
pensarlo como los números que no son
pares es decir no son múltiplos de 2 son
no múltiplos de dos no múltiplos de 2
ahora vamos con los ejemplos cuáles
serían ejemplos de números impares
por ejemplo el 1 es impar el 3 también
lo es el 5 es impar el 7 el 9 y podemos
seguir ahora así como pudimos ver si en
el lugar de las unidades
teníamos un número par quiere decir que
ese número era para todo el número
también aquí podemos ver las unidades y
ver aquí si si hay un número impar en
las unidades entonces es el número es
impar
por ejemplo el 59 tiene un 9 en las
unidades el 9 es impar por lo tanto 59
es impar ahora el número mil 441 tiene
un 1 en el lugar de las unidades
entonces es un número impar 1441 es un
número impar otra manera de pensar en
como como es llamado un número impar
bueno es que observa esto sería difícil
repartir mil 441 donas entre dos
personas de tal forma que a ambas de
toquen la misma cantidad de donas en
este caso sobre una dona entonces a una
persona le tocaría una 2
más no tocarían una cantidad igual a las
dos personas la manera más sencilla en
la que yo pienso en números impares es
que un número impar no es paz no es paz
y ahora que ya sabemos cuáles son los
números pares y cuáles son los números
impares pensemos en qué sucede cuando
operamos con ellos cuando sumamos los
números pares o sumamos dos números
impares entonces pensemos en eso operar
con números pares o impares
qué sucede si yo tomo un número par y le
sumó otro número par par más para este
número la suma será paro será impar
podemos tomar algunos ejemplos para ver
qué patrón surge entonces tomemos por
ejemplo vamos a tomar los números pares
el 2 y el 6 esto es igual a 8
el 8 es un número par
ahora el 14 + 4 14 4 eso es igual a 18 8
en las unidades este es un número par
ahora el número 156 + 4 esto es igual a
160 serán las unidades este es un número
par parece ser que en todos los ejemplos
que he tomado cuando yo sumo dos pares
obtengo un número par y te invito a que
aquí sigues intentando esto escoge los
números pares y suma los y verás que
sigues obteniendo números pares lo cual
tiene sentido porque si yo tomé un
número que es múltiplo de 2 y le agregó
otro número que es múltiplo de 2 tiene
sentido que la suma sea un múltiplo de 2
ahora qué sucede cuando yo sumo dos
números impares ahora vamos con los
ejemplos de la suma de dos números
impares que pasa cuando yo sumo un impar
a otro impar
voy a tomar dos números impares y los
voy a sumar y veamos qué sucede el 1 más
el 3 el 1 y el 3 son números impares lo
sumo y obtengo 4 4 es un número par
entonces sume 2 números impares y obtuve
un número par ahora tal vez este sea un
caso especial tal vez sea coincidencia
pero bueno sigamos qué sucede cuando yo
sumo 15 7 eso es igual a 22 son dos
números impares y cuando lo sumo obtengo
22 un número par esto es interesante
vamos a seguir con más ejemplos entonces
vamos a tomar otros 2 números impares el
19 y el 3
los sumo y obtengo 22 el 22 es un número
par ahora qué te parece si tomo el 23 y
el 5 23 más 5 esto es igual a 28
número par
entonces el patrón se sigue al parecer
es que sucede que si yo tomo un número
par y un número par lo sumo y obtengo un
par pero también si yo tomo un número
impar y le sumo a ese número impar otro
número impar obtengo un par entonces es
interesante cierto intenta los sumas
números impares
y verás que el patrón se sigue seguirás
obteniendo números pares con la suma de
dos impares muy bien ahora pensemos en
una última combinación qué sucede si yo
tomo la suma de un número par y un
número impar entonces par más impar
vamos a tomar un número par le vamos a
sumar un número impar y veamos que
obtenemos sin números pares o números
impares entonces tomó el 2 que es un
número par le sumó el 1 que es un número
impar y dos más uno es igual a 3 un
número impar
ok entonces vamos a sumar ahora 4 3
entonces 4 spar 13 sin par 4 3 esto es
igual a 7 un número impar
y parece ser que si yo sumo par e impar
obtengo impar ahora aquí sólo hice dos
casos pero sigue intentándolo y verás
que de la suma de un número par y unnim
parte resultará siempre un número impar
entonces de par más impar
esto será igual a un número impar ahora
recordando los números pares son números
múltiplos de 2 incluyendo al 0 los
números impares son números que no son
múltiplos de 2 es decir no son pares
entonces un par más un par eso es igual
a para par más par es igual a par impar
más impar es igual a par en par más
impar es igual a paro pero parma sin par
eso es igual a impar entonces parma sin
parar igual a impar para más par igual a
par en par más impar es igual a par y lo
vimos en lo vimos en muchas ocasiones
en estos ejemplos